hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse and we have so much changed
since the last stream and sorry I had to
cancel at the last minute on Friday
stream because well basically I had a
couple things come up all at once about
a half hour before I was supposed to
start streaming at work so yeah so I
decided to get it done and up staying
late on Friday trying to get things done
so anyway so that doesn't happen often
that may be the first time I actually
had to cancel a stream because something
came up with with work so anyway it
probably won't happen again anytime soon
but again sorry for that but the first
thing we're going to do is just try to
go as quickly as we can go over all the
changes and maybe try to explain a
little bit about why if you check out
some of the issues on the github repo
which the link to the repo is now in the
description for this video so you can
check that out there's some discussion
about why we're doing what we're doing
now and but we'll talk about that a bit
before we start coding as well and also
I'm not sure if Brian Sizemore is
watching right now but he is my coworker
that's in the next office write down for
me and I just want to congratulate him
on becoming a full-stack developer which
is awesome
so he's actually been doing a lot of
front-end and back-end work mostly PHP
on the backend he's been doing it for
quite some time but his title did not
reflect that his title you never know he
was
a web developer at all from his title so
now he finally got that change to really
reflect all the work he's been doing so
I'm really happy for him and it's also
cool I can't wait til the next time I
have to do something on the back end and
I could just say all Brian could you do
this I'm the front-end guy right and
pass it off to him but anyway he's a
super nice guy he does drop in
occasionally on the live chat and yeah
it's just super super happy for him and
I just got a message from my wife sorry
about that I normally don't even check
my phone during the stream but it just
caught my eye all right all right cool
cool let me check the the check just
quickly to say hello to everybody
everybody oh cool harsh it says November
for teeth in India is Children's Day so
actually it's probably the 14th are
ready in India what time is it if it's
not already the 14th it's pretty close
because the time difference so anyway a
happy children today I'm not really
familiar with children today but so I'm
not sure if happy Children's Day is the
correct salutation on this day but
anyway I guess have a good time doing
whatever whatever this you do on
Children's Day and cool Bogdan says hi
Jesse watch your streams from the
Ukraine and learn English and web at the
same time thank you for great experience
that's awesome that's really cool that's
great yeah and if you're ever watching
you don't understand some phrase or
something that I'm using just ask me in
the live set I'd be happy to explain it
occasion
I might use some type of like slang term
that may or may not be understandable
even maybe to English speakers outside
the United States so I really try not to
do that
but in case I do please let me know
because I I want you all going to
understand what what I'm talking about
see
okay so it's 12 12 a.m. in India so it
is in fact November 14th which for me is
tomorrow it's still the 13th here
okay awesome all right let's go last
thing a hardship mentioned in a live
chat that I get help right from the
creators so Kyle yeah so Kyle who has
created Gatsby which we had had worked
with in the last stream actually did
comment on some of the things some of
the issues in github which is really
awesome it's really cool when the
creators you know notice things and it
really has nothing to do with me it's
just that you know Quincy let me do this
on free code camps channel and I think
free code camp is well-known and so I
benefit from that and occasionally
someone who's a creator of something
we're using we'll get in touch with me
so the creator of the end Rock which
we're going to use today got in touch
with me before and really awesomely
decided to let us use end rock for free
and have as many connections as we need
for the stream and creator of WP graph
QL and then now the creative gatsby so
anyway anyway it's really cool I
probably would have never gotten to talk
to any of these people if it wasn't for
this so anyway it's cool there are some
benefits I guess to to live streaming
all the time okay all right well let's
get started on explanation I do I won't
be able to go too long that's why I did
the stream a bit early today because I
do have my normal Monday 3:00 o'clock
meeting so let's see so probably in
about an hour we're gonna end the stream
all right so let me I'm gonna remember
to switch my screen now so I know last
time I forgot so now now you all can see
what I'm saying so the first thing I
want to do is paste in the end rock link
so you all can check this out
at the same time and so you'll be able
to see this site in your browser with
this link you can inspect it with dev
tools and it's going to be a lot nicer
experience so I can see you got a bunch
of connections open so awesome okay so
here's what's happened so far as you can
see visually we got a lot done and
really I did very very little basically
just merging things is all I did I maybe
really just minor things
Harshit did most of the work over so
basically since Thursday stream until
now Harshit did a ton of stuff and we
also had a bunch of discussions so
somebody Christian was involved in a
discussion and Kyle from Gatsby was
involved so we had a lot of people
involved in the discussion and it was
really really awesome but here's the
decision that we've come to at least for
now okay so I think we're gonna go with
next Jas I'm gonna keep a branch open
for Gatsby that's gonna have our
original set up with Gatsby and
potentially we can go back to it but
here's here's what happened so Christian
had brought up and thankfully he was
persistent in bringing this up that
there may be an issue when we have
content changing from our content
management system which may end up being
wordpress or potentially something else
but regardless of what it is content is
going to change and with gatsby his
concern was we'd have to rebuild we have
to rebuild our site actually would be
sites because we're running mold
we're going to be running multiple
instances of our site so his thought was
do we really want to rebuild every time
and I that's understandable right it's
going to be pretty big there's gonna be
thousands of pages do we want to rebuild
all that so we're gonna try next because
it's gonna operate a little differently
okay so Gatsby is a static site
generator so everything gets built and
then put on the server well not even a
server you know you you don't even have
to use a traditional server if you're
just serving the static site but anyway
I think next is next is going to be the
better fit for us at least from from the
discussion that we had and we've used
next before if you go back to project
one which was the catechetical Institute
website we've used next there with the
WordPress content management system
using the WordPress API and it works
it's very fast it we get server-side
rendering it's great for search engine
optimization
it really works we were able to set up
things like live search you know pretty
much on our own without having to use
any you know third-party you know
outside search providers so I think
we're gonna go with that and you know if
it comes down to we need to switch later
on that's that's fine which is still
really early on in the project this is
only the third stream so I know we've
already kind of switched or are kind of
free I don't know if you've got a
frameworks or anything but anyway that's
what's happened and if you want to know
more about that you can of course check
out all the pull requests all the
commits and all the discussion about
that on the github repository the link
is in the description and let me show
you the site now and then we started
coding so here's what we have we got our
sidebar right we have our app bar at the
top I'm sorry our drawer we're calling
this our drawer that's what it says in
material UI ok we got this big hero
section with the image this isn't the
image we ultimately go with this is just
a stock image we have our main call to
action here and then just some cards
just it's kind of a demo right what's
gonna happen is we're not gonna have
this login button we're gonna have some
links at the top we're gonna have our
social media icons and we'll have a
search icon here we'll have a spare
check on here with a search field and
then we'll have all our menu items here
probably there'll be expandable menu
items so we'll just have the menu
headers and they can expand out so if
you if you remember our design we were
gonna just redesign the main website but
use the same content management system
and we had started that process before
if you remember we are editing those
c-sharp
you know templates we're gonna use that
same design and bring it over and that's
really gonna help it's gonna save us
time on the design my boss already
really liked the designs so I think
that's it's gonna look nice so today
what we're gonna do is we're gonna try
to make this app bar look just like we
have in our other designs so let me
bring that up so we can compare
so you can check this out as well
Franciscan dot edu slash home test all
one word home test so if you'd like to
check this out and inspect it you can
see this is what it's going to look like
I'll zoom in a bit for you all so we
have a donate button here all of these
social media icons which these are all
inline SVG's right now this doesn't work
on home tests but what's going to happen
is when you click this it's going to
expand just like we have done for the
for the bulletin that we're working on
which is project four so we're going to
be able to reuse that code from project
four which is awesome and these links if
you see what happens when I click one
oops let's refresh it see if I can get
it to work no I don't know what broke on
this but basically what happens when you
click this is that this sidebar sidebar
is not working either hmm oh well I must
have broken something on there
inadvertently then but in any case what
will happen when we click on this the
drawer will open and then that section
will expand to show all the sub links so
will will be able to keep our interface
very clean right off the bat and then
kind of hide away of all the links that
we'll need in the drawer right now the
main website as it currently is is very
busy there's a lot of links there's a
drop-down on hover with even more links
it's so there's a lot going on so we
definitely like to simplify that
significantly so we're gonna make better
use of white space so if you see you
know right here with you know I'm not
100% sure about this layout these are
just kind of examples we're just messing
around with things this footer is
actually going to be pretty close to
what we'll go with as well so we can use
this
as a as an example okay all right so I'm
gonna take this and maybe move it down
here so I can have that visual what its
gonna look like we'll move this up into
this corner and let's get started I'm
gonna start our Pomodoro timer and this
was built by Harshit who's in the live
chat now so if you are in need of a
Pomodoro timer check this out
pom pom da da SH such P om p om dot now
dot Sh really cool and everything's
available on github as well if you want
to check out how he did that all right
so let's start it up 25 minutes of code
take a five-minute break I'll go to the
live chat I'll answer questions and then
we'll try to get another 25 minutes of
code in it's going to be tight today
since I have that meeting coming up soon
but I really will try to get all the
questions answered in the live chat if
at all possible all right so the first
thing we need to do is we can basically
convert this login button to our donate
button change the Styles a bit and then
we need to be able to put you know two
rows in here so we will need to make
this a bit taller because I think we'll
need a bit more space and then we need
to put these in so the first thing that
I'd like to do is go to the material UI
documentation look at the app bar and
see if they have anything built-in that
comes close to any of this if they do
we'll try to use that if not we'll just
do our own modifications so we are using
material UI
and we're using the the beta version and
let's check out our components at bar
okay so if you're not familiar with
material you I it is a react component
library that
is based on Google's material design
standards so we use material design here
at the University is part of our
official web styles so this helps us to
save lots of time by building things you
know with this pre-made these pre-made
components and it looks like I'm not
seeing anything that that looks like
what we need so we're gonna have to do a
lot of a lot of custom work which is
fine yep
then I'm not really seeing anything okay
that's fine with me I really don't mind
I don't mind change modifying things I
think it's kind of fun okay so let's go
in here and find our app bar component
and we'll just check out the code see
what's going on and then test a few
things out I'll just check the live chat
Harshit says we might want to use the
grid there that's a good idea
so we have our app bar here and I'll
make this a bit bigger it's gonna make
sure everybody can see and okay so all
right here's our login button
so I guess right off the bat let's make
this donate and let's check our button
styles
I shouldn't have closed material UI so
just leave it open all the time let's
check out our button styles and see if
we have we already have a style that
will work button Syrio so let's try a
primary button
let's see button raise primary
okay let's try this
colors honey
we need to import primary no okay yep
that works all right let's see what
happened all right great
wonderful that was those uh that may
have worked out better than anything
else I've ever done on a live stream
awesome okay
such a subtle effect now you can see
that that shadow is just so subtle which
is fine you have the color change anyway
and I just wonder I'll have to
double-check the material design
documentation because I'm pretty sure
materialized CSS which is another
material design framework has a more of
a change in the shadow on hover I won't
worry about that detail right now but
this is just something for me to think
about okay great so we have our button
here and let's check out just try to add
in some other things here and just see
where they see where they go just kind
of naturally let's see how they line up
here perhaps we could have some of them
line up in the right spot maybe not
those worth the try all right so let's
go with before I worry about anything
else let's just put something in here so
let's do let's do a div and inside the
div I'm gonna use a span and let's just
put tests and I'm gonna put a few more
just to see where they may end up hmm
nowhere
maybe the there we go I was gonna say
they're probably whites font okay well
good thing is they're lining up to the
right side which is where we need them
actually that that's not bad on that
line there that's a good spot for our
social media icons so maybe let's add
those in yeah let's add our icons in and
then we'll worry about putting our menu
items below that but since since this is
already kind of lining up in the place
we want it we'll only need to make a few
adjustments to get that in the right
spot so what I'd like to do then is just
grab the code for all of this and paste
that in so let me find that I believe I
have that on github so let me check
see Frances at the u.s. homepage so if
you want to check this out some of this
code out from the design this is not
react this is going to be just plain
JavaScript but it's fus homepage so it's
in that same github organization
FUS Markham and this is fus homepage and
if we go into app we should be able to
see this in index dot HTML and here we
go here's our our social icons I'm just
gonna copy this whole thing
just copy that paste it in there
probably gonna be really big and what do
we need to do let's change these classes
to class name whoops now I know there's
going to be it's just added a ton of
markup into our components so there are
going to be better ways to do this
we can always refactor later but for now
we just kind of need to prove we can get
this to work there we go last name and
let me make sure I grab also this and
we'll need to put we need to make sure
that this is and this we need to do this
right is that how we do that
I can't remember how we do how we do
comments and reacts right we can't just
do that we need let me do it like this
don't Lee
whoops there we go
okay so if you've never done a comment
in react within your your render so so
our return for our our render function
you can't just do normal HTML comment
tags right because remember this isn't
really HTML right this is JSX
this is all JavaScript it just kind of
looks like HTML so what we need to do is
do our curly brackets here which lets us
write JavaScript inside of here and then
we use our JavaScript multi-line comment
tags see and now all this is commented
out as far as I know that's the only way
to do comments like this in react so I
do want to add this in I did not create
these SVG's andreas Larsen dead you can
check him out on code pen really useful
you can see all these SVG's are just
super short saves us from having
unnecessary Network requests put them
right in line they load extremely fast
really cool we can change the color the
size on them since they're vector
graphics we can scale them up as large
as we want they'll never be pixelated so
really really like using these so let's
check them out I probably they're all
white so let's change that now let's see
I think we can add some styles in here
hmm want to do this
and I will would actually rather use
regular CSS but I don't know if you have
a file setup no we don't do it okay
I'll do it like this how about this
since we're just trying to see them
let's get our dev tools open let me pull
this over here and make it a lot bigger
okay it's probably still not gonna be
quite as big as we need it for you all
to see but all right here's our button
so we should have there we go should
have these here and are we getting we're
not really getting much of anything in
here oh okay they're all going down
interesting
alright let's see what the problem is
actually you know it would be a great
idea
when we put that why don't we see what
styles we used on here that would that
would be the smart thing to do let's
check out our Styles here all right so
we're looking for social and check our
file SAS file
okay so let's just grab this for now and
see
okay so we were giving them absolute
positioning which actually could work
okay
all right so for now let's just give our
SVG's a width and a color and see if we
can see them on the page this was our CG
greats
all right I think we have 30 pixels as
our with great and they're black right
now so let's give them a color so that's
our green color let's see if that works
no they're still black so I'm just gonna
put a an important in here right now
just so we could see what the green
would be like whoa still nothing
we'll probably need to do is have that
apply to the path then did we have that
oh you're right you know what it's Phil
green not color that was my fault so
with the SVG it needs to be fill there
we go
awesome alright so we have all our icons
wonderful let's see how this works okay
so our hmm our actual links are a little
bit off so we'll have to work on that
but for now that looks pretty good not
bad alright so let's do this then
hmm
I don't think we really need these class
names because I'm not doing anything
special with these icons right now the
only reason I could think that we would
want individual names like this at any
time would be you know potentially for
some tracking but I don't have anything
planned right now so what we'll probably
want to do then
and I don't know if we'll do this now or
not depends on how much time we have so
I'd like to get the other links in the
header what we'll do is just iterate
through an object that has these SVG's
yeah I'd rather not have all this in the
component so we need to have yeah we
need to have some way to change this
potentially we could just take these and
make it another component our social
icons component and then at least that
would get rid of this at that point I
honestly wouldn't even care if we just
left it as is it wouldn't be the
cleanest looking thing but if this was
all there was in that component I'd be
ok with that
so for now I'm just gonna leave it like
this we can move on and get the layout
looking how we want all right and let's
see for now let's just do
let's do our class name as social and
then we will yeah we really don't have a
CSS file huh
hmm
okay let's make sure we have our SVG's
yeah okay
let's add it in here ICG stuff with
30 pixels fill whoops I was supposed to
be a comma Phil besides two one four one
two a whoops which I probably could have
brought yeah I could have brought this
color in like this let's do that that's
the better way to do it
okay all right so let's do that and then
let's take all of our instances of SVG
and then let's add oops how are we
adding this that wasn't close was it
yeah it is okay class name classes dot
let me just call this SVG style
okay I'm gonna save that see if it works
just make sure
okay great that works wonderful
I mean shake my timer okay but just
under four minutes and then I'll go to
the Live Chat check everything out
answer some questions okay
see what we need now all right so let's
throw in some of these links and then
afterwards we'll try to put this in this
is also an SVG so let's just grab what
we have again from from this demo we'll
grab the code and you know at some point
these aren't going to be hard-coded in
and we're also going to have URLs for
all of these which are all not going to
be hard-coded in either we'll want these
to be changeable and actually I'm not
sure about that the odds of the URLs for
our social media changing and really
small so maybe it's not worth it
but these links you know potentially we
will want to change these at some point
all right so let's get let's go back
to our index.html and we'll scroll down
so here's all of our icons will go below
that and here's our lengths okay
so it's just an unordered list but when
here we go we have our search input
included in there so I think this will
show up we may have to put some Styles
in here as well but we may end up with
white font color at first so probably
won't see it but once we change the font
color it should be alright so let's put
let's put this after our button yeah let
me see where this toolbar component goes
from okay
yeah we'll put it right after the button
whoa something's not right
Oh what's going on so we have something
not closed ICG div there we go
inputs not close so remember when you're
working with react everything has to be
closed so even a thing like an input
where if you're doing normal HTML you
don't have to include this slash to
close it you you do have to include it
in react thankfully you know we have our
syntax highlighting and it was
immediately apparent what we needed so
it saved some time and we're gonna have
to change all these classes to class
name so you said it I think it is class
name and if we have let's check our
inputs ID class name time all right okay
I think we're good wonderful all right
so I'm gonna save that the timer just
went up style okay it looks like we have
some inline Styles wool on our next
Pomodoro session we'll address that but
for now we'll do a five-minute break let
me scroll all the way up to the top of
the live chat so I don't miss questions
got to keep an eye on the time so I
don't miss my meeting and I'm gonna take
a drink I'm back on the the the G fuel
so it's like an energy drink
I haven't had G fuel for like a month
I've been doing like espresso and coffee
but this has a lot of vitamins in it so
I figure it's probably healthier for me
so anyway not than any of you really
cared what I was drinking I'm sure
just says thanks I'm from Mexico awesome
thanks for watching
I've actually I've never been to Mexico
so I'm from the United States and I'd
like to go down there I had somebody who
who I know know some people who are
gonna open up like a tech school
somewhere in Mexico and he was going to
try to talk to him and see if they'd be
interested in me coming down and giving
a talk to some of the students which i
think would be really cool so I don't
know what's going on with that I haven't
heard anything about it for a while but
that would be it would be cool I'd like
to go paul says hi Jessi your stream
with Gatsby Jess let me down the rabbit
hole and caused me to rewrite my entire
application nice we're just going to say
thanks you're welcome I'm glad you're
thanking me for for having you write my
entire application you could have been
annoyed with me I guess so that's cool
if you're still watching and if it's
possible I'd love to see what you're
doing so if it's on github please share
share that link with me you don't have
to do it in a live chat if you don't
want to you can DM me on Twitter but
it'd be really cool to to check out what
you're doing and if you need any help
open an issue and maybe if I have some
time I can submit a pull request for you
kiss your it as says can someone say
what is going on I'm new to Jesse's
videos
looks like got some answers to that yeah
creating erect harsh and says creating a
react next J s site for the university
yeah that's that's basically the answer
if you want to know more about it check
out the first video in this series so
it'll be project 5 day 1 of the video
title is I think planning a react
project so
check that out and I go through a much
longer explanation of what's going on Oh
Harshit says next four is faster now
much faster since next to which is what
we use in the catechetical Institute
site awesome I'm really excited to see
it yeah I mean I I figured that next
that had updated a lot because I know
from the first time I use next when it
was pretty young
until that catechetical Institute site a
lot had changed so I figured that it had
changed even more I'm really impressed
with how quickly next updates and adds
new features so we got a lot of people
working on that staying on top of things
see
all right Gino says Ola Ola Gina I my
Spanish is not that great
she
let's see I think my time is up just her
to go off
and see
all right Gina says kay-kay framework s
its react and we use next js2 kind of
scaffold it out
so those kids alright Gina says alright
Sugino speaking in Spanish so if anybody
knows Spanish and can help letting me
know which you know saying I'd
appreciate it so far I can pretty much
understand me saying but I haven't
really worked for Spanish that much
since I was in college so it looks like
Gina wants to learn JavaScript great
let's see
we are definitely using javascript also
says Java web development mobile
development totally cool yet we we're
definitely doing JavaScript no job Java
but we are going to do some maybe some
react native which is mobile development
gino also wants to learn how to program
and Gina hopefully you you're
understanding what I'm saying in English
I went so Gina wants to make a Facebook
trying to make a Facebook clone is
pretty challenging but you know stick
with it no doubt you'll be able to do it
it looks like hush-hush it's as speaking
with Gino in Spanish in the live chat so
that's great so anyway yeah let me know
do you know if if you can understand
what I'm saying enough I assume you can
my Spanish is is not good enough for me
to actually teach in Spanish
unfortunately okay let's get back to
this and check the time a little okay
I'm gonna try to another Pomodoro
session but I went a little bit long on
that last break so we'll see if I can
get it in or not I do need to do some
prep work before my meeting so let's
just see if we can get a little bit more
done and then we'll go to the questions
sorry I clicked away from my my
dashboard for the livestream and now I'm
trying to find it okay I got it back
okay okay so we had problems with our
Styles all right so let's check this out
so we just copied in everything in this
ul it looks like we have some inline
Styles that aren't working
because inline Styles don't work like
they do in plain HTML when you're doing
things with reacts so let's find it
UO closed then style whoa we just had an
empty style tag that's weird
all right let's see if that was it whoa
okay cool that was definitely it but
we've got ha ha we've got a bit of a
mess going on here right we didn't bring
over any of our Styles for this so let's
see let's go back to our CSS see what we
have going on or I'm sorry our sass we
have a class name search icon
okay let's try to find search icon there
we go
okay so we're floating this left
SVG pointer all right let's bring over
you know what I'm gonna move this over
to my other screen quickly so I can copy
this over faster so we need on let's see
we have another SVG as well right we do
but it looks like we have some inline
stuff going on that should be fine for
now okay so on this SVG let's take this
class name out
this is a different one huh
I think this would be all right okay so
let's take this class thing out let's
add classes and this will be search SVG
yeah that works and now let's put this
in up here SVG and we need to add in
cursor:pointer whoops this needs to be a
string great and we're gonna give it a
width of 27 pixels and fill so with an
SVG weak we use fill for our color and
we're gonna give it the same color that
we had here and notice that I'm not
writing regular CSS Co this is actually
a JavaScript object so a little bit
different but you can see the the
property you know this kind of operates
this operates just like a class name
would alright and these are the
properties and the values so the only
difference with the properties where we
use camel case and let's just put in
padding let's see I don't want to mess
with the padding yet because we may have
some differences so I'm just gonna leave
it as is for now and see what it looks
like all right so let's check that out
first okay great
so that's a more reasonable size and
color awesome actually we may want to
yeah we were gonna pull some code for
this input right I've forgotten about
that so I'm not going to do anything
else with this input or the search
or anything because we're gonna replace
that with a code that we used on our
last project but I do want to change
this a bit so let's figure out where
we're getting this this list from hmm
let me just search
what I meant where we're getting the
styles for this list from so I okay so
what are we calling this it's hoping to
have links okay let's check out my other
screen I'm gonna check out the styles
for top and I have links whoa I'm not
finding any styles
huh
so we did have we had that on there from
this class what else do we have
see what he said eyes display this an
interesting Oh looking at the wrong one
here here we go
alright let's put some of these on here
didn't really make it better there you
go float:left
this style type known
oops
I put it on the wrong thing I'm sure you
all notice that oh sorry about that
that explains why it's not really
working okay oh goodness you all can't
see that it's behind the screen I'm very
sorry about that okay
anyway yeah so you can see we do have
let's take
see where we have a so sure let's let's
play around a little bit in dev tools
and see what we can do position let's
try fixed and let's go top eight pixels
and left and a right 16 pixels great
except we want more than that right
because we need to fit that donate
button in there so let's just try 50
then a hundred try hundred pixels first
okay and then let's do the same with the
donate button so we're gonna do a
position position fixed and we're gonna
go again with top zero oops top eight
pixels and then left this time we're
gonna go 16 pixels Oh what do we end up
interesting let's get rid of that for a
second
oops I did just did the wrong one here I
said left didn't I oh yeah here's a
button I meant to say rights 16 great
all right now 16 pixels from the rights
is a good space so let me try to zoom in
and show you it's hard to see but
basically you can see that scroll bar
goes right in here if you go less than
16 your scroll bar will start to overlap
whatever you have there and this is is
on you know on iOS you have a thin
scroll bar on Windows the scroll bars
tend to be even thicker so minimum I go
from the side is 16 pixels so you know
keep that in mind and I usually do the
same on this side at least 16 pixels
just to keep things the same but you can
certainly go more than that but if you
want to give yourself you know as much
space as you can up here you know 16 I'd
say is the minimum amount or I'm sorry
the yeah that's an the minimum amount
okay great so we need to move these over
a bit now obviously this is not good
spacing let's go back up to our social
social div and that's not bad spacing
now let's try 116 great okay I like that
spacing I like it the only thing I don't
like is right now it I would like it if
all of this you know kind of the same so
we may want to make the donate button a
little bit thinner or you know maybe
push these down just a bit
I'm not worried about it right now
at some point we might want to do you
know one or the other a combination of
the two you know to make it so that you
know these are kind of middle you know a
line Pro you know potentially align
right with this text but for now that's
not bad that's working out all right so
before we accidentally refresh this and
lose what we've done let's take these
and transfer them over to our react
component so I'm going to move this to
the side here so I can keep it on the
screen while we edit this so we have
above our SVG style I'm gonna put our
social I'm gonna call this social and
that's going to be of course our our div
that holds all our social icons and
we're gonna do position:fixed and top
it's gonna be eight pixels right we'll
be do we do one hundred and sixteen
pixels all right awesome we're also
going to do just few G let's do our
button so let's call I don't want to
just call a button because we have a lot
of buttons secondary CTA this is our
secondary call to action I say that
because our primary call to action is
going to be this button this is our
secondary one so we actually do need to
play around with these sizes because I
would want this to be larger and this to
be a bit smaller right
this is primarily what we would like
users to do which it doesn't say it
right now but this will prompt potential
students to fill out an application and
then secondarily for people who aren't
students we would like them to consider
donating so we want those you know
definitely visible
and easy to click right off the bat okay
great
so let's put our social and our
secondary CTA classes down here was a
social class name so we already have
social here which is great let's just
gonna wrap this here and classes dot
social and then let's go down to our
button and let's give it classes the
secondary CTA let's check out what we do
as you saw oh I forgot the comma I
frequently forget commas in arrays I'm
sorry
objects this is not an array it's an
object I great that I get all the commas
I did it okay
oops and I missed well I missed what did
I do and what time wow what did I mess
up all right let's check this out
and I do down here
mmm
alright let's restart the server usually
when things go weird it's always worth
it shot to restart the server
this was happening me earlier
occasionally all the Styles would just
go away and the only way to fix it was
to restart the server all right awesome
so that's working again now yeah and I
forgot to add the styles here for this
list so I'm gonna have to redo that whoa
and you know what I messed up the
positioning for that button so what we
wanted was 16 pixels not 1/16 so that
should fix that and now let me let me
grab those the styles for the list don't
we had before that was that I get those
I'm gonna pull it over to this screen
and there we go all right so let's make
our bar links I'm gonna leave these in
here now but these are gonna be replaced
but for now it'll keep that search icon
small enough so it doesn't look crazy
and we're gonna do we're gonna call
these links at bar app bar links
and we're going to say I'll see we'll do
a couple things
let's go line-height and we do 48 pixels
this would be the last thing we do
because I'll never get through the
questions if I don't stop right now
Heights actually alright yeah I have to
stop now so let's let me put this
comment so don't get an error and how
about I stop this now and I'm gonna go
ahead and commit this as is and then
that way if anybody wants to check out
what was done you can otherwise that
won't be able to commit it till after my
meeting so let's get status check out
great so we've only modify the one
component which is what we anticipated
and let's go get at git commit a.m. and
let's say add social icons that's good
enough
great git push origin wonderful ok now
that's on github now you don't need that
anymore now let me go to the live chat
I'm gonna try to get through as much as
I can I can only do about 10 more
minutes that I have to go to the meeting
if I really have to I could pry bring my
laptop to the meeting and I get the data
I need while somebody else is talking so
but I'd rather not have to do that in
case I get asked for my data first okay
oh great I see Graham and Harshit both
let me know in the live chat how to do
the comment in react so thank you for
that sorry I didn't look over at the
live chat I really should have ended up
figuring out anyway but but still I
appreciate it
that's seed Tim asks where do most
technical discussions take place for
this project github Gator slack
wondering what is the best way to stay
up to date or find out if there is
something I might help with I would say
probably get hub and actually I would
prefer this so all the technical
discussions should take place on github
preferably in issues or if a pull
request has already been submitted for
something within that pool request that
way it's available to everybody we don't
have to worry about somebody you know
getting you know sign up for Gator or
getting into the slack Channel I think
that's the most public place and then it
keeps it all central so even you know
let's say two years from now somebody
happens to find this repository our
slack Channel and our Gator it might not
even be active anymore but they can
still see the logic behind everything
you know not that anybody would be
interested in this two years now but you
never know so yeah so check out the
github repo and usually all the
discussion happens
Scott has yawning all the discussion
happens within the issues there that's a
really good question
let's see
cool rook says the SVG's looks nice he
says SVG's are cool but complicated yeah
they are I really like these SVG's
because they're so simple you know the
the actual you know SVG code is just
very simple for those a lot of them can
get huge like this is an SVG this icon
and it's really just huge write the
codes huge is it's hard to figure out
what's going on but something like this
you at least have a shot at being able
to like look at the code and figure it
out not me I'm not really that
knowledgeable about the code but
somebody who is into SVG's could
probably figure this out since it's so
small but you can do a ton of really
cool stuff with SVG's there's somebody
on Twitter
Sara Dresden Sara her I I follow her on
Twitter and she's always doing really
cool stuff with SVG's and I've seen her
videos come up on YouTube before as well
so if anybody is really interested in
SVG's and the stuff you can do with them
check check that I'll check her their
Twitter account out and maybe try to
find her stuff on youtube but I'm always
impressed with what she's able to do
with with SVG's
music says putting classes to the class
name happens to me all the time and
react yet it happens and actually for
one project we had it set up I forget
who set it up but somebody set it up so
that you could actually use class and
you didn't have to use class name and
then I got spoiled with that and so for
the next project I kept messing it up
again
let's see bill all says what do you guys
think about CSS grids versus flexbox
would it be a waste of my time to try to
learn both I guess it depends if you're
into CSS and you want to learn more
about it then go ahead and learn both if
you're more like of a back-end person at
all mess with CSS that much but wouldn't
worry about it quite as much but if you
usually use let's say a framework where
it's kind of an abstraction of class
names you don't have to deal with it
directly then you might not want to but
if you're really interested in how it
works then the reason why you couldn't
check both out it's not super complex I
think the hardest part is just trying to
remember what the the property names are
and the values that you can give them
Oh heart should actually paste it in the
name of the the plugin where you can use
class instead of class name so thanks
for that yet it's it's um babble plug-in
react HTML attributes but it's attrs so
check that out if you want to I can see
it coming in handy if you had to paste a
lot of regular HTML into react I don't
know how much of that we'll be doing you
know aside from what we just did here I
think that's about as much as we're
gonna need to paste in so we should be
good but it would be useful if you did
have to paste a lot God soul says what
University the University I work at is
called Franciscan University of
Steubenville it's a small University in
southeastern Ohio in the United States
if you're familiar with Pittsburgh it's
pretty close to Pittsburgh just just
west of Pittsburgh
okay let's see Bogdan says I learned
flexbox uses some test projects and now
started to learn CSS grade Peter says
you have to learn flexbox before CSS
grades
Bogdan says kid because you can use CSS
grids with flexbox
world's asked what did you study in
college business officially I have a
Bachelors of Science in Business
Administration with a specialization in
banking finance and economics it's a lot
to fit on on a resume but yeah that's my
that's my degree
let's see
Rick s regarding hang react versus
angular what in a nutshell is the
biggest difference regarding the
learning curve personally I found
angular to be more difficult to learn
than react but I tried to learn angular
back when it was angular 1 and I was a
lot less fluent in JavaScript so it's
not a fair comparison when I tried to
learn react it was a couple years later
I knew a lot more so I don't know that I
could give kind of a fair answer to that
question from my experience
all right how about 10s is there anybody
who knows there's something on Russian
unfortunately I don't really know very
much Russian at all but I am good with
Google translates you'd like to say
something in Russia and I will translate
it and it's here hey Anna how's it going
thanks for thanks for joining us in the
live chat
see
ha ha brooke says look how crisp this
huge icons are it's amazing yeah I mean
the icons being that big were definitely
is not intended but it was a good
example of how crisp the SVG stay yeah I
just love it
so cool
okay Bogdan says are you coding and
react yes now as I understood you write
some Styles in JavaScript file right
what is it can you explain okay man I
got into a meeting I'm sorry I won't be
able to explain this very well but at
least I could show you yeah this is
react and this is a JavaScript file and
then we're writing the Styles here but
we're basically just creating a
JavaScript object and then we're
applying those Styles down further in
what looks like our HTML there's a lot
of different ways to do that in react
this is not the only way but I don't
have time to explain any of the other
ways let's see okay all right so
unfortunately I really have to go to my
meeting now so thank you so much for
watching and helping out we got a decent
amount done today almost everything I
really had planned on getting done and
if you have any questions and I didn't
get to them feel free to DM me on
Twitter or reach out to me on any social
media I'm on most of them I should be
back tomorrow around the same time 2:00
p.m. Eastern time until then thanks
again and have a great day